welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar the NIH
micro physiological systems program
presented by dr. danila Tagle an
associate director for special
initiatives Office of the Director of
National Center for advancing
translational science National Institute
of Health my name is Susie Valdes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
elaborate lab routes is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational and virtual
events and webinars before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation just simply click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of the screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to you and your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have any trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation just
click on that ask a question box and let
us know you're having an experiencing a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits without further ado please join
me in welcoming our presenter today dr.
Denis Lu Tagle welcome dr. Tagle yes
thank you Susie for an introduction
and I'd like to go over the NIH
microfiche logical systems and
essentially provide a general and broad
overview or the program and tell you
what's currently going on in this
program and then also lead into future
direction so this would be my outline
I'll start with telling you a little bit
about the the National Center for
advancing translational sciences where
am i associate director for special
initiatives there and as I've said I'll
work you through the
micro physiological systems program tell
you about the partnerships that we have
in them going to future directions so
the National Center for advancing
translational sciences was stood up at
the NIH the National Institutes of
Health back in 2012 and its central
mission is to catalyze a generation of
innovative methods and technologies
essentially to enhance the development
of an implementation or diagnostics and
various therapeutics so you can tell
right away that it's very different from
the rest of NIH which is focused on on
specific disorders or organ systems so
what we're really about is to serve as a
catalyst in terms of resource and tools
development that would aid in terms of
quick implementation of there's
therapeutics and diagnostics into the
clinics now if you're familiar with the
drug development pipeline there's
certainly a number of stages and
targeted development all the way to
clinical trials and currently the
paradigm is to use a variety of tools
and technologies that includes us 2d
cell cultures and in vivo animal models
and before getting into human trials
however there are many significant
challenges in drug development
currently the average length of time to
develop and bring to market a particular
drug is is on the average from 10 to 15
years with a cost of 2.6 billion dollars
and so the the current drug discovery
our paradigm is a failure rate of 90
percent 55 percent of which is due to
lack of efficacy and an additional 28
percent is due to toxic effects in
humans so what we need in what in cats
is trying to address is to create tools
that would be better predictive of the
human response some of these candidates
are qyx if you look at the safety and
efficacy issues a good number of the
failures is because we are using
currently animal models that are not
predictive
the human response one of the recent
publications indicate that no matter
what animal model you use whether it be
a dog model Montana even non-human
primates rodents and this is a recent
paper looking at 4000 plus or 4,000
drugs that have gone through FDA
approval over the past 70 years indicate
that probably dogs would be at best
predictive about 25 percent as well as
stress for various human conditions but
generally all this animal models are not
necessarily useful in predicting human
response and and that is where the the
microfiche illogical systems program or
the initiatives come into play so
essentially what we have are a
multi-organ microfluidic device that
that contains human cells and tissues so
just to walk you through what what a
micro physiological systems look like or
tissue in a chair you will have a
scalpel which which means having the
right access element matrix represented
in the system
cell sources that are not mono layer 2d
cultures but essentially multicellular
cell types that represents the tissue
composition and representation of a
particular tissue system or organ
systems and also coming from renewable
sources such as stem cells like induced
pluripotent stem cells or primary cells
structure such as the rigidity and
porosity or the particular tissue is
also represented in this system as well
as spatial and temporal patterning that
includes cytokines from ingredients even
oxygenation gradients also represented
worstest since this are 3d cell culture
system perfusion is an important factor
where nutrients oxygen
in embarrass pH are balanced and
represent the actual physiological
conditions the bioreactors includes
biomechanical transduction properties so
that the actual tissue types undergo by
mechanical stimulation innervation
Indian host responds are also critical
features that we're trying to present in
the systems as well as functional
readouts that would include non-invasive
real-time imaging in this system so this
is just a general representation of what
a future looked like and I've said it's
really trying to represent
physiologically as well as in terms of
the site to Architecture of particular
organs and tissues in using real-time
imaging and omics based technologies to
have the capability of newer waste of
evaluating response of these devices so
the MCATs tissue shape a drug screening
program just to reiterate essentially as
a central goal for eating this in vitro
platforms that uses human cells and
tissues and its central goal is to
represent at least 10 major organ
systems the circulatory the endocrine
system the GI immune system skin
musculoskeletal system the nervous
system from a reproductive respiratory
and urinary system with the goal of
making a physiologically relevant
genetically diverse and of course needs
to be pathologically meaningful it's
intended to be modular that is it can be
reconfigured such that individual organ
system can be plugged in into other
organ systems to form multicellular on
the multi organ or to the point of
actually parading a human body and a
chip and at least by ability of the
cells and tissues for at least four
weeks just to give you an example of how
organ function is represented in this
organ system so for example if you look
at the law
reduce that to the basic functional
element so we're approaching it from a
reductionist approach where you look at
the air sacs of the alveoli as the basic
functional unit of Allah and that is
represented on the right hand side of
the alveoli as the device were in cyclic
vacuuming creates this negative pressure
that allows a membrane containing shown
in blue the lung epithelial cells and
and below that endothelial capillary
cells which would undergo stretching are
similar to what would happen in the
alveoli also the the process of the
stretch actually stimulates the lung
cells to form surfactants and be much
more responsive and representative of
the actual condition under in the air
sac and I'll show show a demonstration
with that later on so there are a number
of platforms engineered platforms that
are now represented in the NIH tissue
chips programs and the one on the top
that panel would be the actual tissue
chip that is being used to represent the
lung and then the one in the middle it's
a micro vasculature in a chair where you
can actually embed tissues in other
[Music]
tissue constructs that just even tumor
cells to device colorize that particular
tissue construct the one on the right is
a kidney on a chip which contains the
proximal tubule of the kidney the bottom
left would be a an example of an
integrated multi organ systems in this
particular case this is the female
reproductive system that contains the
fallopian tube on the chip contains the
uterus ovary the actor cervix can also
connect
to deliver on a chair which would then
inform drug developers in terms of how
hormonal changes in this case a female
[Music]
cycle can influence drug metabolism by
hooking this up into the deliver and the
the one on the right is also another
example of an integrated multi organ
system that contains the skin deliver
heart and bone in this particular case
so there's a bright white variety of
micro engineered platforms as well as
the different ways that organs and
tissues that are presented in the system
just to give an example of how this
models are being used to pre to predict
for example efficacy so here's an
example where DeLand long linen ship is
used to model unary edema where it's
very hard or not difficult to model
model this condition in any animal or
even in vitro system so the scenario is
to look at il-2 chemotherapy which is
used primarily syndication for kidney
cancer and melanoma but has the
unfortunate side effect in a few
instances of vascular leakage syndrome
so in the bottom panel is shown the
lamina chip and wherein you seeing fitzy
labeled inulin you can see that yeah if
there is the label dinnerland will will
traverse through the capillary and lung
epithelial cells are showing leanest of
the capillary that and going into the
lungs which would be representative of
pulmonary edema however if you then
incorporate before inhibits or into the
system still with the 10% strain
stretching you can see that in leakiness
vascular leaking
is mitigated in the presence of truth
before and so showing that this
condition can essentially be prevented
or can be sort of a companion drug to
il-2 chemotherapy
another example that I'd like to show is
the functional integration of various
tissues on a chip systems on this
particular case linking up the deliverer
the kidney proximal tubules with the GI
system or the car along with the
neurovascular unit or a carbon barrier
informing how multi organ connectivity
can influence or inform how drugs can be
metabolized in the system so an example
of that would be looking at Arista
kolodziejczak acid which uses the
property in the number of cases so this
is known to be congested to Chinese
herbs medicine which primarily used
being used for a diet it's company comes
from the planner is the lochia and when
ingested and have come through liver
metabolism is shown in the picture in
the figure here the in the presence of
liver and kidney the proximal tubular
kidney
shown in red undergo apoptosis and that
is shown in the diagram where the or
just the kidney cells by itself treated
with IRA silicic acid are viable whereas
when the kidney proximal tubules are
connected to deliver and the iris
technologic acid undergoes metabolism i
converts re silicic acid into its
sulfated form which is then nephrotoxic
and and then the mechanism
she can also be shown in the sense that
the sulfated conjugate form
enters the kidney through OAD
transporters which can be blocked by
related treatment with professing it as
shown in the the bottom right hand
figure where the treatment progressing
it essentially renders the proximal
tubules to be viable and this is shown
by staining for live dead cells in this
particular case just to give you an
overview of what has been going on in in
the first five years of since the
inception of this program so the NIH has
supported this program for the first two
years to develop the platforms and as
well as great to sell resources and then
the last three years from 2013 to 2017
who has essentially to validate the
systems that is are these models
actually representing the tissue and
organ physiology and then using a
training set of compounds that
AstraZeneca Pfizer and GSK guided us in
terms of what to use so essentially this
training set of compounds are molecules
or chemicals that have gone through
preclinical assessment and has been
approved by the FDA for human trials but
subsequently has been withdrawn because
of adverse events instead a question it
would be that we're asking is with this
model system the tissue chips would the
human response have been predicted ahead
that the animal models and in vitro 2d
culture systems was unable to predict
and so that was sort of like the the
activities that have been going on in
the last three years for the program
from 2013 to 2017 we have also partnered
with a number of government agencies
such as DARPA offering the Department of
Defense
where their primary interest is in
developing the the tent organ system or
the human body on the chip and then the
FDA is a non financial partner but
essentially providing NIH with key
regulatory advice in terms of how to
qualify invalidate the system for
regulatory decision making so out of the
five years of the program number of
publications have already come out over
500 of them in various high-profile
journals in some ways informing the
scientific community in terms of how
this or various for tissues on the chips
can be and is being used in drug
development now just to give you the
current landscape of what the NIH tissue
share program looks like we now have
four very active consortium made up of
investigators as shown in the bottom
right and this chip developers with Asia
tip 2.0 showing the virus academic
institutions for in all this activities
are going on and cats especially form a
leadership role in in providing support
to make this technology move forward
with the fish a cure 2.0 that is now
actively moving forward from 2018 for
the next five years to model diseases
there's diseases and I'll show you a
little bit of what those diseases are we
also have a number of partnerships both
within the NIH
shown in the top left corner also with
the number of pharmaceutical companies
to GSK asses Anika Pfizer and thermo
Fisher and also to the IQ consortium
also with the number of governing
agencies such as the FDA NASA DARPA and
Barda what is interesting is indeed
is there support at NIH has continued to
provide also
to start out and spin-off companies that
have come from the academic institutions
that are now seeking to commercialize
this model systems and those are shown
in yellow a key out of the partnerships
we have with the IQ consortium at the
can in the FDA are the tissue chip
testing centers in the tissue chip
database centers shown in green and I'll
tell you a little bit more about that in
subsequent slides and also tell you a
little bit about our partnership with
NASA in the Center for advancement of
Science in space shown in red and on the
top right corner in terms of how we are
taking advantage of unique conditions in
space on both the advanced biology as
well as the technology in this program
supporting disease models which is the
Bishop 2.0 we're essentially looking at
monogenic or photogenic diseases in
either in Julian or multi factorial and
how this could be modeled in various
tissue chips water through single organ
or multi system involvement for the
disease pathology in essentially what we
are striving to do is to develop various
readouts not only used in conventional
staining and biochemical analysis or
enzymatic analysis but also using only
space technologies real-time imaging
that are non-invasive gene expression
studies which can then be used to inform
and correlate with with the in vivo
human condition
looking at absorption distribution
metabolism excretion concentration
inverse toxicities and then be able to
do the in vitro and in vivo
extrapolation studies to inform and
completely continue to improve our model
system so in in order to inform
how these devices this micro
physiological systems can be used to
model diseases we first started with
rare diseases as a way to work into the
system because typically those are
single until Yamada genetic genetic
traits and so we have our district
developers partner with another in cots
program which supports the rare disease
clinical research consortium shown here
in red or work directly with patient
advocacy groups shown in yellow and so
out of this activity a number of rare
diseases especially vascular
malformations lysosomal storage disease
tuberous sclerosis kidney disorders
liver disorders and in heart and a
number of neurological disorders as well
has been modeled using the system which
then led into a home loan program which
were calling district 2.0 which is then
focused more on disease modeling and not
just on great diseases but certainly on
multifactorial in polygenic disorders so
shown here are the current efforts to
model to use the stationers to model the
earth diseases from ser estonia which is
a static dry drying of the salivary
gland it's a consequence of chemotherapy
which is a single organ modeling to
multiple organ involvement such as in
type 2 diabetes shown in the bottom
right in blue box where in various
groups are modern exact 2 diabetes by
connecting for example the pancreatic
beta-cell islet cells will deliver with
GI system and with adipose tissue to
accurately depict
what's going on in type 2 diabetes
so there are certainly a number of
opportunities in applying to searches
for rare disease research and especially
for using patient-derived IPS cells to
populate these tissues this can also be
used to look at multi-organ involvement
there are many rare diseases and then or
of course be able to evaluate without
necessary compromising the patient to
evaluate multiple treatment approaches
in parallel it's so that and so then it
protects the patient naive status until
the best treatment option is identified
so with this effort one of the examples
is looking at for example bark syndrome
which is an excellent recessive disorder
caused by a mutation in the face injury
and from some acts it is caused by a
severe cardio Lippman deficiency in
essentially characterized by
cardiomyopathy and it's one of the rare
diseases about one in three hundred
thousand birds and so this is how its
represented in the tissue on the chip
where in cardiomyocytes
from patients are put into a muscular
cartomizer ten films were in in a
beating rate in terms of the retina city
of cardiomyocytes beating is is captured
in the system as a sorcerer like a
cantilever type device readout where the
bit rate is measured in terms of the
deflection of the cardiomyocytes in film
so in this particular case taking
patient-derived IPS cells and either
also putting them on chips and then also
taking isogenic lines
I suspect ideas oxygenic lines and
through our genome editing incorporating
the same changes the same mutations on
those normal isogenic lines to make sure
that the
the actual pathology is due to the
mutation and then being able to evaluate
in this system their use candidate
therapeutics that could help mitigate
some of the cardiomyopathies in this
particular disease so this is an example
of the BART syndrome on a chip or the
cardiomyocyte shown in in Figure a
that's the Titian ship with a
microelectrode array figure D would be
the circle sarcomere organization shown
in labelled with acting in and then the
figure C would be the top figure would
be a normal car to my site from from a
normal individual or non heart syndrome
patient and then the one in the middle
would be showing the cardiomyopathy from
a Bart syndrome patient and then the
bottom would be treated with in this
particular case treated with a cDNA that
corrects the mutation in the IPS
cardiomyocytes by showing restoration of
the sarcomere structure this is also
shown in in the beat gray I guess the
video is not showing but essentially
what you would have would be
slowly-slowly the beating in the left
hand corner of D and then the one in the
middle would be cardiomyocytes from Bart
patient that is showing the
cardiomyopathy and it's not beating or
hardly beating and then restoration of
the contractility of the Barre syndrome
cardiomyocytes when treated with radical
oxygen species scavengers or treated
with C DNA that restores function into
discarding my sex what I'd like to show
- as I mentioned that there are a number
of startup and
companies that have grown around this
technology and shown here are a number
of those companies that are either
commercializing the actual chips
themselves or in the process of
providing pink paper service to test
various therapeutics you know in the
system
next would be you know showing how
Pharma in the FDA is also showing a
great interest in the use of organs on
chips in terms of drug development and
regulatory decision making so for
example recently in 2017 the FDA has
actually signed a collaboration with
emulate essentially to bring ambulate
technology so emulate is one of the
companies startup companies that are
seeking to commercialize the longer
nature of the GI and a chair to burping
beer in the chair now insert the FDA is
looking to set up and has set up a
facility within the FDA campus in using
the emulator technology likewise they
have also partnered with cn bio which is
commercializing the liver and chair as
well as the multi organ platform
likewise to test that platform at the
FDA and then recently they also have the
FDA also have a public hearing and in
terms of how this type of new technology
in vitro technology can be used to
predict human responses to wide range of
substances in terms of Pharma interest
Johnson & Johnson and Mark have also
partnered with emulate in terms of using
this organ and chip technology in terms
of the drug development pipeline and
similarly AstraZeneca
had was a partner would emulate to set
up based tissue chip based technology as
part of their drug development pipeline
in terms
they're laboratories in Sweden so I work
with with the pharma companies of
Bloodshy being facilitated through the
IQ micro physiological systems affiliate
IQ consortium at this state consists of
representation from about 20 pharma
companies all interested in engaging
with tissue chip technology and in
looking at how this can be used to
inform drug development by looking at
drug metabolism in some of the safety
and issues looking at bio distribution
of the drugs and essentially because of
this IKEA consortium members member
companies can essentially compare notes
and be able to provide input to the nih
as well as the FDA in terms of how the
best deploy this technology in drug
development
so part of what are the activities that
we've had with the IQ consortium in the
fda is essentially to create a
validation parent framework where in
this technology can be used to build
confidence in how it can be effectively
used in drug development and so we view
this as essentially three steps in terms
of validation on the physiological or in
the organ function in structure is
validated and represented and discipline
merrily done with this chip developers
as I mentioned earlier this is done
using a training set of compounds that
was informed by a satanic adviser and
GSK we also have the second stage which
is the analytical validation and it is
this is largely conducted by independent
testing centers and essentially looking
at technology transfer to these
laboratories and being able to
determine the reproducibility
reliability door vastness and relevance
of individual organs and chairs and how
they can be used for just using a
validation set of compounds that was
guided by the IQ consortium at the FDA
and as I've said this is done through
what in cats stood out as the Taoiseach
tick testing centers where data is also
collected through the tissue chip
database centers lastly the industrial
validation stage is where industry and
regulatory agencies would then start
adoption and commercialization of this
technology and started testing them
testing on them proprietary set of
compounds and largely done through a CRO
type environment so just to give you a
little bit of flavor and tour in terms
of the t-shi chip testing centers so so
an cats has established this as a
Resource Center funded initially for two
years starting in 2016 and we have
recently renewed there for another two
more years of funding we do go that
after the after 2020 that they will be
self-sustaining and being able to
generate revenue coming in from their
interactions with various stakeholders
in the field as I've mentioned FDA and
IQ consortium was was was critical in
providing guidance on the validation set
of compounds so let's attack with essays
and biomarkers that will be used in
terms of independent validation of each
of the organ systems so the testing
centers that we can cancel funded
through MIT or at Syria and Alan
Ritchson scare the pee eyes and then
also Texas A&M University we're even
mr. main PID database the microfiche
logical systems databases house the
University of Pittsburgh and pi4 that is
mark Sharda and so on the bottom are the
list of the various tissue on chairs or
organs and chips have been have gone
through initial testing is testing
centers in validation and just recently
the first publication coming out of the
testing centers was published in Nature
scientific report and that was done by
the kidney on a chair so the idea here
is for each of the testing centers to
test each of these organs on chips in
parallel essentially to look to be able
to independently validate how useful the
technologies how easy it is to transfer
the technology from the developer to the
testing centers and being able to
replicate the findings to the validation
set of compounds creating best practice
and being able to identify what the
primary opportunities are used in this
technologies as well as the identifying
some of the limitations as I mentioned
we have renewed the testing centers for
another round of funding Windigo
transitioning them into a
self-sustaining model so with the MIT
testing center which is transitioning
into CRO Javelin Biosciences and they
have a business model of working with
some startups and spin-off companies
that are commercializing some of these
technologies being able to validate the
systems as they come in to market the
Texas A&M University is the business
model of working with the Bishop
developers in looking and validating
disease models looking at some of the
more improve dishes and chips
some of the more subsequent iterations
an improvement and also looking at how
number of the systems can be used for
advocacy testing one one exciting thing
and I'd like to indicate with is the
partnership and Cass have with NASA in
the Center for advancing science and
space and this is essentially looking at
opportunities that bands organ and chip
technologies both in terms of looking at
biology as well as technology
improvement so one of the main things
that we're looking at would be some of
the changes that happens under
microgravity conditions in space and so
this is done with research but the
International Space Station so
astronauts have gone through four long
stay at International Space Station
undergo a number of physiological
changes so within three weeks that they
are up in space they undergo upper-body
huge share your back neurovestibular or
inner you changes my sleep disturbances
Boeing didn't organization from three
weeks three to six months they also
undergo bone resorption muscle atrophy
vascular deconditioning GI disturbances
hematological changes and then anything
in more than six months in addition to
all of the above they they also have
declining community being install
information all of these changes happens
in a very short period of time in the
interesting observation is that the when
the astronauts returned to Earth normal
there's reversal to normal physiology
within a few weeks two months on when
they return to Earth and so this affords
us an opportunity to then to look at
some of these changes and be able to
figure out what instigate some of this
changes under microgravity determine
what the molecular signatures are and if
you know some of the special article
changes this are essentially some of the
presentations
that would remind you of aging so in the
short period of time that the astronauts
are in space actually undergo
accelerated aging which then reverse
back to normal when they return to Earth
so gives us an opportunity then to
identify molecular signatures that can
be used as perhaps as novel targets for
drug development there can mitigate or
prevent subtle dis conditions which can
be applied for use on earth so the
findings can be translated into novel
drug develop into novel drugs that can
be used for for us here so in terms of
the projects we're looking at immune
senescence we're looking at bone and
joint problems issues with integrity in
the brain barrier looking at infection
primarily in the law looking at
proteinuria and kidney stone formation
sarcopenia looking at also
cardiovascular deficiencies and and then
also some of the GI disturbances so this
gives us the an opportunity to to model
the systems which otherwise would have
taken longer to create this models here
on earth
perhaps years but we could essentially
model these changes within weeks at the
International Space Station by deploying
the tissue chips they're being able to
then do the analysis and figuring out
what those changes are molecularly and
then as I mentioned creating reducing
that opportunity to create novel targets
for drug development well one of the
other things that we're interested in
would be to vastly improve the
technology for organs on chair so and
when I talk to the astronauts going up
to space and our beam will be the ones
running it
good number of them are not training a
scientist they're primarily coming from
military background and so they said you
know you need to make the system robust
automated essentially turnkey technology
or in short they call it make it
astronaut by the pilot proof and so that
obviously poses a large challenge for us
as this ship developers so just to give
you an example if we are to conduct an
experiment on 24 ships here on earth
which and so this would be essentially
looking seventy-two samples what we're
looking at would be multiple syringe
bombs you know four incubators each of
which are 48 cubic feet multiple to
beings large number collection vials but
of course they really constrained in
terms of real estate the National Space
Station so the requirement would be
essentially a 1.6 cubic feet instead of
48 cubic feet on earth everything has to
be shrunk in size be automated and be
able to essentially miniaturized
everything down to the size of a shoebox
but this can be done through
partnerships with NASA cases and in some
of the space implementation partners
like space Pharma stars that shot space
dangle and visor in terms of
miniaturizing making decent return key
technology which would then facilitate
the adoption of this improvement to make
this support instrumentation easily use
here on earth could become then a
benchtop instrument that even an
undergraduate student will be able to
push the button and be able to make it
run which would severely uncomplicate
things in terms of getting the
experiments running here on earth just
to show you that this is
actually reality and has actually gotten
great strides and so we had our first
launch this is actually a picture that I
took at the Kennedy Space Center
SpaceX 16 launch that contains one of
our partition ships that studying in
unison essence and this would be
followed by another launch in March
scheduled for March although things
could change depending on the launch
scheduling
again this will be from for spacex 17
one of the three of our future projects
coming up in 17 and another one
scheduled to go up in April the Wallops
Flight Facility that would also contain
one of our tissue chip projects now to
tell you a little bit more in terms of
what in Kansas planning or is currently
supporting in terms of future
initiatives and how we're going this
program more so essentially looking at
the developments in tissue chip
technology we're looking at looking to
do clinical trials on chips and social
that'd be coming soon so essentially
looking at how these fish chips can be
used for precision medicine creating
individualized on a chip we also have
the nociception on a chip pain on a chip
which is an active solicitation right
now shown here with the RFA t our number
1900 3 as well as creating an immune
system on a chip and those are two
active solicitations right now in terms
of how we can continue to grow the
program one of the things that also have
come about recently is the ability for
the station ships to be able to address
and provides some solutions to the
opioid crisis you may know over 25
million people in the u.s. experience
pain and certainly opioid misuse in
detection is an ongoing crisis the
United States the administration in
Congress the Senate
they put a lot of focus on this area
since more than 90 people die every day
from drug overdose so get this is
something that the NIH has focused on
essentially was given five hundred
million dollars a year by Congress to
look at this crisis and so the NIH
created a new program and when called
heal which stands for helping to aid to
end addiction long term and essentially
t-shirt chips was able to get some money
to use digital technology to be able to
model pain opioid misuse as well as
overdose and so that is the subject of
the current solicitation and as I
mentioned the new program that is
forthcoming would be to use partition
chips essentially for clinical trials
and shifting from clinical trial design
essentially to be able to provide
information in terms of the optimal way
by which clinical studies can be
deployed for example by identifying the
right population stratification or
subpopulations that are most responsive
to a particular treatment and be able to
inform how those drugs can be marketed
and in package for FDA approval
so in summary I'd like to summarize the
tissue chips are more physiologically
relevant they essentially constitute the
microwave architecture to Oregon provide
tissue tissue interface precise flow
perfusion and innovation and a
biomechanical queues are represented as
well spatial temporal chemical gradients
and essentially being able to
be able to accurately predict human
response in the system and we died I'd
like to end my presentation and thank
you very much for listening in
thank you dr. Tagle for that informative
presentation I'd also like to thank the
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that this will be
available for on-demand through May 2019
a final reminder dr. Tagle will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now and thank
you for joining us we'll see you next
time bye-bye